so
when you and bill broke up
what did you miss the most
his big
oh yeah rachel bilson isn't holding back
when it comes to her ex bill hader it
was pretty crazy what started as casual
chit chat on her broad ideas podcast
ended in the oc alum giving a cheeky
response about the berry star whom she
dated in 2019 for about a year so
when you and bill broke up
what did you miss the most
his big
[Laughter]
and you can keep that
all right rachel we hear you loud and
clear ew
but i like it but this isn't the first
time rachel's been honest on her podcast
about their breakup back in june she
revealed just how tough ending their
relationship really was i went through a
really hard breakup and it was during
the pandemic and i could not leave my
house like i couldn't you know what i
mean and so i had nothing else to do but
sit in it
and deal with it and feel it and like
it's probably the hardest thing i've
ever done harder than childbirth even
though like it hurt like a mother
but yeah but like if you actually face
it you can come out of it and be like
okay rachel and bill first met when they
co-starred in the 2013 rom-com the to-do
list
audi neighbor i'm not your neighbor
and i was doing wilson the neighboring
improvement whatever
but at the time bill was married to the
film's director maggie carey i was very
proud of her too i was just so kind of
like wow you're making the movie this is
so cool and rachel she was dating her
jumper co-star hayden christensen can we
please go someplace four
where do you want to go
surprise
but fast forward to 2019 following a
divorce and breakup the two sparked
dating rumors with a coffee date in
bill's hometown of tulsa oklahoma and in
2020 the pair made their red carpet
debut at the golden globes
and get this their romance came as a
complete shock to their to-do list
co-star aubry plaza who appeared on a
previous episode of rachel's pod you
know bill and i dated right
what
are you serious that's why when i wrote
that to you in the text
i was like i don't know if aubrey
actually knows this
no
you didn't know that
no
i swear to god like two years ago
right when the pandemic hit i went with
them to the golden globes but your
characters dated in the movie and we
wound up dating but by july 2020 bill
and rachel called it quits and now all
that's left to do rachel's sitting back
and having a laugh about what once was
so when you and bill broke up
what did you miss the most
his big
[Music]
you